Good morning John; it's Friday, April 22nd.
So, I made a video for today, uh, and it's
all ready, it's all edited, it's ready to
go. Due to circumstances beyond my control,
which I cannot explain to you at this very
moment, I cannot put that video online.
So now, I have to make another video. Gyeahh.
So since my planned video for today kind of
fell through, now I have to make a video in
the old school way. The way that I used to
do it where I just, uh, talk to the camera--
hi!
This is a prop for the video that was supposed
to go online today - it's a hundred pennies
in a cup. And this is a prop from my nerd
jokes video - it was around the lens. I don't
actually keep my duct tape there. Maybe I
should - uh, it's a place to keep it! Less
clutter.
Speaking of props, astute Nerdfighters who
watch every one of my videos - thank you very
much for doing that - have recently noticed
that my posters, uh, the one that's right
there, seems to keep changing. And that is
correct, I've been doing that for a while
now, where I rotate through posters because
I feel like, you know that's a space that
I can do interesting stuff with. And that
is the map of the Realm of Narnia.
Speaking of good Nerdfighters who I appreciate
greatly, if you've been around since the rap
of the melm of-- rap of the melm. If you've
been around since the map of the Realm of
Narnia days, uh, I am amazed.
If you don't know what I'm talking about...
"I love... that, right there, you see it?
That's a map of the Realm of Narnia."
Good Lord. I just went and watched that whole
video. That was January 5th, that was like
my, my third video ever on YouTube. Wow.
And that, uh, co-starred with me! I recently
discovered, it was made in 1972! It's very-
it's pretty old! And so I went online... that
thing sells on eBay for like 80 to 100 dollars.
And it's not like I haven't been fond of the
map of the Realm of Narnia, but knowing that
it's worth 80 bucks, bound to be a little
more careful with it in the future.
So anyways, posters, I've decided that I want
more posters in my life, so I'm going to do
a rotation. Every video, new poster there.
And the first comment that tells me what that
poster is of, uh, you will get... nothing.
DFTBA Records has not, to this point, done
posters, but I am obviously a fan of posters.
So I want to do posters, but we need some
good poster designs. So I'm going to be looking
into that. Ideas for good poster designs in
the comments please.
I have a tiny The Cheat, also I got him along
with my Strong Bad poster-- why is my chair
doing this?
[sped up talking]
Finally stopped. I'm dizzy. I should show
you, my feet aren't touching the ground. Leg-crossing
is one of my only stupid human tricks. I can
get into a full lotus without- without touching
my hands. And now you've seen my feet. Uh,
they're big, and not very attractive. Hiii!
John, we've been doing this for a long time;
when I went back to check out the Narnia video,
it really sort of hit home. Also, the amount
of amazing stuff that has happened to us.
And that we have been able to accomplish because
of this.
This, for example, like this is not something
that I could've done without - why did my
door just open? If I had had this idea, and
I didn't have Nerdfighteria to sort of as
a launching platform for it, I couldn't have
done anything with it. Nerdfighteria is there
to support me and the hare-brained schemes
that I have.
And it's everything from that to, like, me
humping stuff on Tumblr - yes, I know I didn't
mention it in my last video, but don't worry,
I was impressed. And then you have more serious
stuff, like the Project For Awesome and the
fact that I was able to go to Haiti to examine
the work that non-profit organizations are
doing there.
I sit here in this chair and I make videos
- I can't express how thankful I am for that,
and this probably should be, like, the video
that I make when we get 500,000 subscribers,
when I'm like "oh, thank you all," but I don't
need a special occasion. So somehow, this
video turned into a thank you video. I would
also like to thank ticky-tacky, for helping
to affix my posters to the walls. Uh, 3M is
not sponsoring this video.
You may have noticed, we don't do much in
the way of sponsored videos. Why do I need
to do sponsored videos when I have my own
things to sell? Speaking of my own things
to sell, these are available on Amazon, I-
I know not everybody has a Paypal account
or wants a Paypal account, so now you can
buy them on Amazon.
Portal 2 is going well, I just uploaded the
second episode, uh, sorry it took me so long
to get it online, but MAN IS IT FUN!
John, thank you as well; I hope you're having
a great time in Amsterdam, and I will see
you on Monday.
End screen time! I just wanted to show you
this picture I just found of John Green, uh,
this was when I was in college, so he was
just out of college, and this is my dorm room
in college. We had a dartboard - that is the
dart, John is throwing it - and he's super
freakin' skinny!